ce n'est pas dans le paris de
l'introuvable mais depuis quelques jours
les femmes de la capitale peuvent
trouver des hommes qui se déshabille sur
scène ils s'appellent les chippendales
et se produise plus ou moins dénudées à
l'elysée montmartre
rassurez-vous la revue reste pudique les
maires américains torse bombé se
contente d'être suggestif et apparemment
ça plaît si j'en crois sabine gorny et
bénédicte banner première à se porter
volontaires pour retourner le reportage
qui suit chaud très chaud devant vous
nous émoustiller ils ont sorti la grosse
artillerie à fantasmes cuir jeans troués
17 beau mâle california bronzé ville et
vos divisé qui nous l'ajoutons rue
deux heures de show très pro à
l'amérique elle ils dansent chantent se
trémousse mais gardent leur string rien
que pour vous mesdames que l'aménageur à
la femme d'affaires on est venu entre
nanas pour mater si beau gala
alors ça vous a plu
[Musique]
viens pas ici de pouvoir à matthews
j'ai dit pour voir le mec quichotte
qu'ils emmerdent encore
des habitants surtout solitude aux actes
hier me parle partout assabah en 13 ans
ont fait vibrer plus d'un million de
femmes dans le monde
allons c'est l'hystérie à paris début
s'immiscer bouche à oreille qui remplit
la salle alors fou à coincer c'est
parisienne pourquoi vous en sus de
l'ordinaire s'exprimer vraiment fort
alors parce que ça va prendre un peu de
temps avant que les emplois
ça y est ça le gourdin
vianne
c'est con droite pour en arriver là
c'est bull travail trois heures de
culturisme six heures de danse par jour
régime draconien et épilation du corps
deux fois par semaine les poils c'est
tout sauf sexy être un homme objet ça se
mérite
les femmes dans le public désolé il ne
les regardent même pas tant pis on veut
partir avec le string chippendales en
souvenir
ça coûte 40 mais que voulez-vous les
fantasmes
on n'a pas de prix